partout dans le monde des aéroports sont
devenus de vastes stationnements
l'industrie aérienne est presque
entièrement paralysée et le canada n'y
échappe pas l'impact est catastrophique
parce que l'activité est en pratique
arrêté le besoin est urgent pour un plan
de sauvetage
certains transporteurs ont vu leurs
revenus fondre de 90 % et leur survie
est menacée même cloué au sol il faut
entretenir les appareils maintenir du
personnel est payé les dettes
l'industrie demande des liquidités soit
des prêts sans intérêt ou de l'aide
directe il faut payer nos dettes
il faut rester à flot pratiquement
toutes les compagnies aériennes montrent
indépendamment de leur taille du pays
sont dans une situation de faillite
potentielle
jusqu'ici ottawa n'a pas répondu à
l'appel de détresse alors que d'autres
pays ont agi la france et les pays bas
par exemple ont volé au secours d'air
france klm en mobilisant 11 milliards
d'euros
pourquoi le canada tarde-t-il à
intervenir
on est là on est lent comme si on
accorde pas ce secteur-là toute
l'importance qu'il a dans le métro une
éducation en effet qu'un programme en
développement et du tout ses traits et
keita le gouvernement trudeau rappelle
que sa subvention salariale a permis à
air canada et westjet notamment de ré
embaucher du personnel
il a aussi allégé de 330 millions de
dollars
le fardeau des administrations
aéroportuaires quelle sera la prochaine
étape
nous évaluons toutes les options pour
soutenir l'industrie écrit le bureau du
ministre des finances du canada
toute aide supplémentaire devra venir
avec des conditions réclament des
groupes de protection des consommateurs
de rhénanie élèves sachant que l'argent
ne servent pas à verser des bonus aux
dirigeants et des dividendes aux
actionnaires et que les voyageurs soit
entièrement remboursé si leur vol a été
annulé en raison de la pandémie les
industries fragilisés se multiplient et
les demandes s'accumulent sur le bureau
du ministre des finances
un casse tête qu'il doit démêler
rapidement en ordre de priorité tout en
s'assurant que l'argent public est
dépensé de manière responsable
ici louis blouin radio canada ottawa